Adie thanks for joining us where are you
calling from hey Dan thanks for having
me I'm actually calling you from
Singapore Oh what when did when did this
become real not not finalized but when
did it become real for you I think we
started to really sit down with the UFC
and have conversations on how we could
all come together to make this happen
you know this has been something that
we've been thinking about for a while
since Floyd kind of started the social
media banter back and forth your honor
but I think early on it was really still
a vision but not to many other than I
think Floyd Connor and our team really
saw as being a real viable opportunity
and then once a nature started building
up and you just started to see really
what the fans want to see this they were
really sat down with us that that was
when it started to feel real and I think
credit to all parties involved you know
going through the negotiation process
figuring out you know what's important
to all parties and then being able to
really connect the dots and and make a
deal is unprecedented you know I think
we spiced unprecedented what we've done
just in regards to having kind of
crossover and andfox arguably the
greatest boxer of all time is
unprecedented and I think this event
will be unprecedented I think that the
fans are going to walk away feeling
really happy because everybody thinks
you know the up to the naysayers think
that China's walking in there for a
payday but he's going to know to compete
he going into the chakra world and he's
kind of had that type of approach and
chip on his shoulder throughout his
entire and young fight career that's far
so this fights no different the stakes
are are really high and we're really
happy with from a business standpoint
with how the deal ended up but but make
no mistake about it you going in there
to compete when they notice shocked the
world any discussion on something
different with the ground rules other
than 12 rounds of boxing no I mean
obviously this is boxing so you know
you have to to comply with with those
rules is not mixed martial arts so I
think it's gonna be your your
traditional boxing match you know it's
not going to be any type of a hybrid or
or you know some makes martial arts
rules that are added to it not at all
this will be a full-on boxing
competition here was my idea on this
Audie and that is if you had five rounds
boxing and then after that it was five
rounds MMA that put Floyd on the clock
that he had to knock out Conor because
if it got past that then it got really
interesting if we're making a spectacle
of that right that that to me that if
it's going to be a spectacle then that
makes it I mean that takes it to a
different level there so none of that
ever came up well I know there's always
been chanting right who could winner
what type of fight at this stage of
floyd career i doubt he would want to
even take that take that chance right I
mean ultimately when you're saying
unarmed combat and anything goes you
know that that traditional boxing now
could put void in some real danger right
so I don't think it was something that
they were ever going to entertain and
yeah there was
I think worse said but there was I think
more so just just it she's just in good
humor knowing that for he's not going to
necessarily want to want to take that
challenge did Connor and Floyd ever get
to the negotiating table together where
they ever in the same room no on the
phone nope so they've had no contact no
the only conduct they've had is through
social media and I think that the
lead-up to this fight will be the first
actual contact so it's going to be
really interesting to be really
entertaining you know obviously I'm part
of team McGregor but you know I'm a fan
of this as well as well so I'm excited
to select every other fan just to
witness the fight but I'll
so just the entertainment aspect of the
build-up I think it's going to be a lot
of fun and and then you're gonna you're
gonna see a real competition you're
going to see a guy who I'm a whether
he's trying to go fifty you know he
doesn't want to blemish on his record
he's not going to take this lightly I
could tell you Connor is not going in
there just to get a payday that's done
already
he's going in there to win and compete
because you had some lofty goals and
he's very ambitious and and you know
this is this is not the end of our
career
but regardless so I am here Audie is is
he is this a one and done as far as
fighting a fighter for Conor McGregor
well I don't think you can rule anything
out right now right i mean i think you
let's just say we go in there and knock
floyd out that we mixed and we're
probably going to have to rematch him
you know so i can't tell you that it's
the last boxing match that that Conor
made may partake you buddy tell you he's
definitely planning on fight mixed
martial arts yeah why understand okay
can he make too much money in this that
he doesn't need to go back to MMA that
he just had a baby is there a bigger
plan for him of being a movie star
Hollywood you know doing what the rock
did it feels like once you're going to
you know you got a hundred million that
you've made or whatever it's going to be
you might be less likely to go back into
the ring and get your head banged in a
little bit well look I think you've had
a very successful career you've been
fortunate enough to meet a lot of great
athletes in your career and I think you
could agree with me that that's the
human element of all this stuff depends
on the individual so yeah as it relates
to Conor I just know how ambitious he is
athletically from a business standpoint
so for for a lot of people for most
people we make that type of money were
okay with that let's retire and go
Island that's it we're done hey good
crack me a corona I just want to eat
keido's out there but for Conor he's
very ambitious he loves what he does he
loves to compete he's still in this you
know he's not even 30 years old yet
right so I think he has some unfinished
business in terms of what he's trying to
accomplish his professional career and
yes there are
they're post athletic identity plans
that we have for him as we do with all
our clients and we've already started to
put those things in motion but I don't
think those are those are necessarily
tied to whether he's going to fight one
last fight or not he was very ambitious
he's a trainee tell you again is there
any agreement what's a few more of these
like payday
well is this a one and done with Floyd
is there an agreement in place that
there is more than one fight with Floyd
Mayweather gnome you know depending on
our this is just this is the one this is
a one fight this is a one fight you okay
you still want to fight you but if Floyd
goes 49 and one I mean what do you think
oh boy coming back oh yeah Floyd's
coming back you want you yeah he'll want
a piece about it yeah absolutely
okay what do you think this is going to
make which is going to make is this 500
million or more I mean you all
indicators point to the fact that this
should be 500 million more right yeah
it's a global event see the fan interest
the public interest is just is off the
charts
so all signs point to this being a very
successful event where you're having
billions upon billions of people tuned
in from all over the world and so you
know but but time will tell mm-hmm
should be interesting and and you know
for Peter you gonna be there are you
coming yeah are you coming are you
inviting me can I bring out like a belt
like jimmy jimmy kimmel bill can I can I
bring it if you say I can bring out
Conor McGregor's belt I'll be there for
you okay I thought you said can I bring
out a goat I'm sorry go I like to style
you already something that he's the goat
I I will bring out a belt and a goat
signifying Conor McGregor is the
greatest of all time look it's just from
one of Irish tough guy to another I'd be
happy to be there for Conor McGregor if
he needs it come come sense to whisky
with us that night you're more than
welcome you're definitely invited no no
am i bringing the belt into the ring is
what I want to know is this an official
I'm sure here well you know I'm gonna
have my people call your people on that
that work man I didn't think you guys
were afraid of anybody you're big you're
a big imposing figure man I know that I
know that if I walk in mayweather may go
damn that guy is a lot taller than I
thought he was going to be and then
they'll say like Dan Patrick not kind of
a guy guy hey
steak travels we'll check in with you
and you let me know you want me to be in
the ring I'll be in the ring and if I
have to take a piece of somebody I'll do
that too I love it I love it all right I
say thank you buddy
all right Audio thar he's kind of
McGregor's agent what an official invite
there it felt following why I felt like
the Burger King guy going in the ring
got a little bit more run than I just
did the freaking Burger King guy got
into the ring with Mayweather Pacquiao
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience